bonsoir falek jeanjean merci d'être avec
nous on imagine que vous avez suivi
cette très longue conférence de presse
de jean castex et pourtant pas beaucoup
de mots pour vous les restaurateurs
toujours pas de date
en tout cas de réouverture votre
réaction
écoutez vous savez de toute façon qu'il
n'y aurait pas de réouverture possible
dans la posture du gouvernement monsieur
delfraissy l'avait dit on a bien compris
que de toute façon le gouvernement ne
sert qu'un autre porte parole de
monsieur delfraissy depuis quelques
temps nous on avait fait des
propositions
les propositions censées évidemment
prouver technocrates c'est quelque chose
de compliqué c'est selon lui ces
propositions censées c'était 2 est donc
parti de la france dans le sully fait
pas trop trop froid on peut mettre nos
terrasses à disposition pour que les
gens puissent manger ou de s'agglutiner
sur des bancs au soleil là où ils le
peuvent de manger un peu n'importe
comment de se regrouper dans des bureaux
c'est aussi le cas dans l'établissement
on respecte protocole sanitaire des
gestes barrières
je rappelle quelque chose très simple le
cas il rappelle que nous avions mis en
place personne d'autre de l'ami en mis
en oeuvre la grande distribution les
centres commerciaux les gens circulent
cette lutte il
c'est normal alors que chez nous il
était à distance et il devait laisser
leurs coordonnées
nous sommes les seuls endroits où ça a
été fait et maintenant ce n'est plus le
cas dans les transports en commun il
pourrait y avoir la possibilité avec des
smartphones de se faire l'europe de se
faire identifier
ça pourrait de la possibilité ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose nous
savons très bien que nous ne pourrons
reprendre une activité normale qu'à
partir du moment où nous y aura une
immunité collective que ça passe par la
vaccination que on se rend compte que ça
tarde que ça met du temps on voit que
par exemple israël est arrivé ils ont
confiné tout le monde ils ont dit voilà
on confine tout le monde pendant un
certain temps et en bas à vacciner
pendant cette période-là eh bien ça
produit des résultats des effets et ils
ont un objectif auquel avril pour
pouvoir se remettre au travail pour
pouvoir ouvrir donc là pour l'instant
qu'est ce qu'on a on nous fait cette
annonce mais ça fait depuis le mois de
décembre qu'on savait qu'après les fêtes
de fin d'année
il y aurait une poussée épidémique que
on allait alors nous confirmait ce
qu'ont annoncé aujourd'hui les gens moi
parce que c'est intéressant ce que vous
nous dites vous avez raison voilà il
serait là à vacciner 20% de sa
population déjà ils ont payé plus cher
le vaccin vous en voulez à quoi à
l'europe parce que entre parenthèses les
voisins européens c'est pas mieux les
restaurants sont fermés chez eux aussi
c'est cette lenteur européenne qui
posent problème selon vous on la lenteur
et les parts au pnl et technocratique
vous faut pas se leurrer nous avons des
hauts fonctionnaires en france dans des
énarques et puis on a aussi des hauts
fonctionnaires à bruxelles
la tg l'accident elle est européenne
elle est européenne mais la difficulté
derrière elle et ensuite sur les prises
de décision localement sur le territoire
il peut y avoir des possibilités quand
je vous parle d'ouvrir les terrasses
il est terrassé chauffer bien évidemment
parce qu'on est quand même en hiver ça
c'est pas l'europe qui va le décider
quand on parle quand on voit que les
restaurants d'entreprises restent
ouverts où les gens vont s'agglutiner
c'est pas l'europe qui intervient là
dessus
quand on voit que les aides sont
décaissés la partir de donneurs ont
demandé les aides pour le mois de
décembre mais les loyers les crédits
tous a déjà été payée prélevés sur nos
comptes
pour ceux qui ont encore un peu d'argent
on pensait comme peu d'argent de toute
façon c'est rejeter est ce que les aides
qui vont arriver doivent servir à payer
des agios pour les banques c'est aussi
une autre question
alors je vous propose justement et
frédéric jeanjean d'écouté bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie qui
s'est exprimé sur ces points fait ste
mans je veux simplement confirmer que
nous maintiendrons en janvier les
exonérations de cotisations sociales et
les aide au paiement des cotisations
sociales qui ont été mises en place en
décembre
l'objectif est simple zéro charges
sociales pour les entreprises qui sont
fermées ou qui sont lourdement pénalisés
dans les secteurs liés à l'hôtellerie le
café la restauration le sport
frédéric jeanjean tout de même savourer
conforte un petit peu oui mais ça fait
des mois qu'on l'attend ça fait des mois
qu'on attende tout ça est con on attend
que les des choses concrètes des
propositions qu'on a fait
trouve à l'écho et à chaque fois il faut
lever le temps il faut engager un bras
de fer il faut il faut vraiment se
mettre dans des situations pas possibles
pour pouvoir arriver à obtenir gain de
cause
là l'heure actuelle on nous annonce
qu'on va pouvoir repousser le
remboursement du prêt garanti par l'état
on parlait de ce report c'est à dire
qu'au lieu de rembourser en cinq ans
jean bourse hollande quatre ans est-ce
que ça va aider nos entreprises à
redémarrer est-ce que ça va aider la
trésorerie
je ne le crois pas je vous donne un
exemple très concret mon établissement
sur l'année 2020 puisque en fin d'année
on a tiré le chiffre d'affaires j'ai
perdu 260 milles euros les aides de
l'état puisque on dit que les
restaurateurs sont inondés d'argent de
la part de l'état sur 200 je suis sûr
c'est plus de 252 millions que nous
avons perdu nous avons eu un peu moins
de 30000 euros dead
ça c'est du concret et nous avons perdu
53 % de notre chiffre d'affaires
alors aujourd'hui a évidemment beaucoup
de patrons de restaurants de bars qui
sont désespérés
vous vous êtes au combat mais certains
n'ont même pas la force de s'exprimer
d'ailleurs un patron de bar s'est
suicidé dans les vosges emmanuel macron
lui a rendu hommage et promet que les
restaurants ouvriront dès que possible
un commentaire un commentaire vous avez
ça fait des mois qu'on averti de cette
situation des mois qu'on se bat qu'on
soutient les confrères par tous les
moyens possibles on a même fait un
système de banques alimentaires pour les
aider on ira contient par les cheveux on
les accompagne bien sûr que cette
situation on l'annoncé on l'a dit on l'a
expliqué au gouvernement et on fait tout
pour essayer de résister parce que il
faut pas qu'à la faillite économique et
la crise économique qui vont arriver
s'ajoute en plus des drames humains
parce que je vous lire on peut rebondir
on peut repartir
même si c'est plus difficile en france
que dans d'autres pays mais on pourra
repartir
tant qu'il ya de la vie il ya de
l'espoir mais il faut justement pouvoir
maintenir cette possibilité d'espérance
et où est l espérance aujourd'hui vous
avez un monsieur castex notre premier
ministre avait annoncé que ce sera
l'année de la gastronomie
cette photo me il ya personne tout est
fermé et ensuite il a dit maintenant ce
sera l'année de l'espérance ou de
l'espoir je sais plus j'ai écouté ce
serait bien qu'elle arrive parce que si
c'est comme pour la gastronomie
ça va poser quand même un problème de
fond merci beaucoup frère erik jan van
secrétaire général umit rêve d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et bon
courage à vous